what i want to do in this video is talk
about the two main ways that triangles
are categorized the first way is based
on whether or not the triangle has equal
sides or at least a few equal sides and
the other way is based on the measure of
the angles of the triangle
so the first categorization right here
and all of these are based on whether or
not the triangle has equal sides is
scaling and a scalene triangle is a
triangle where none of the sides are
equal so for example if i have a
triangle like this where this side has
length three
this side has length
has length four
and this side has length five
and this size side has length five then
this is going to be a scalene triangle
none of the sides have an equal length
now an isosceles triangle is a triangle
where at least two of the sides have
equal lengths so for example this
this would be an isosceles triangle
maybe this has length
this has length three this has length
three and this has length two notice
this side and this side are equal so it
meets the constraint of at least two of
the three sides are have the same length
now an equilateral triangle you might
imagine it and you'd be right is a
triangle where all three sides have the
same length
so for example this would be an
equilateral triangle
and let's say that this has side
two two and two or if i have a triangle
like this where it's three three and
three any triangle where all three sides
have the same length is going to be
equilateral
now you might say well sal didn't you
just say that an isosceles triangle is a
triangle that has at least two sides
being equal wouldn't an equilateral
triangle be a special case of an
isosceles triangle and i would say yes
you are absolutely right an equilateral
triangle has all three sides equals so
it meets the constraints for an
isosceles so by that definition all
equilateral triangles are also isosceles
triangles but not all isosceles
triangles are equilateral so for example
this one right over here this isosceles
triangle clearly not equilateral all
three sides are not the same only two
are but both of these equilateral
triangles meet the constraint that at
least two of the sides are equal
now down here we're going to classify
based on angles an acute triangle is a
triangle where all of the angles are
less than 90 degrees so for example
so for example
a triangle
like
let me a triangle like this
maybe this is 60 let me draw a little
bit bigger so i can draw the angle
measures
so triangle
a triangle
and then it's a little bit less i want
to make it a little bit more obvious
so
let's say
a triangle like this
if this angle is 60 degrees
maybe this one right over here is 59
degrees and then this angle right over
here is 61 degrees notice they all add
up to 180 degrees
this would be an acute triangle notice
all of the angles are less than 90
degrees
so less than
90 degree angles for all of them
a right triangle is a triangle that has
one angle that is exactly 90 degrees so
for example
this
this would be
this right over here would be a right
triangle maybe
this angle or this angle is the one
that's 90 degrees and normal way that
this is specified people wouldn't just
do the traditional angle measure and
right 90 degrees here they would
normally write do this little
they would draw the angle like this they
would put a little i guess you could the
edge of a box looking thing and that
tells you that this angle right over
here is 90 degrees and because this
triangle has a 90 degree angle and it
can only have one 90 degree angle this
is a right triangle so that is equal to
90 degrees now you could imagine an
obtuse triangle based on the idea that
an obtuse angle is larger than 90
degrees an obtuse triangle is a triangle
that has one angle that is larger than
90 degrees so
let's say that you have a triangle that
looks like this
a triangle that looks something
something like
this
maybe
this is
120 degrees and then let's see let me
make make sure that this would make
sense maybe this is
25 degrees and maybe this is 34 or maybe
that is 35 degrees
this is 25 degrees notice they still add
up to 180 or at least they should 25
plus 35 is 60 plus 120 is 180 degrees
but the important point here is that we
have an angle that is larger that is
greater
greater than 90 degrees
now you might be asking yourself hey sal
can can a triangle be
multiple of these things can it be a
right scalene triangle absolutely you
could have a right scalene triangle in
this situation right over here actually
a three four five triangle a triangle
has lengths of three four and five
actually is a right triangle this right
over here would be a 90 degree angle you
could have an equilateral acute angle
acute triangle in fact by
both all equilateral triangles because
all of the angles are exactly 60 degrees
all equilateral triangles are actually
acute so there's multiple combinations
that you can have between these
situations and these situations right
over here